every cough sniff and wobble by russia's
president triggers rumors he's ill
that vladimir putin was clearly well
enough to travel to iran this week
and now the heads of mi6 and the cia
have rubbished speculation he's
terminally sick during rare public
appearances in the u.s
there's no evidence that
putin is suffering from serious ill
health as far as we can tell he's
entirely too healthy
it's not a formal intelligence judgment
russia's leader has always tried to
portray a macho image bear chested
or showing off his judo moves
denting that impression is useful for
his foes especially since russia's
invasion of ukraine
a top ukrainian intelligence officer
even told sky news in may that putin had
cancer
perhaps more wishful thinking
though images like these of russia's
president using a blanket during an
annual victory day parade have helped to
trigger speculation he is battling some
kind of disease
as the driving force behind the war in
ukraine putin's state of health matters
the head of mi6 used his appearance at a
security forum in colorado to offer this
stark assessment on how badly he
believes the russian military is doing
i think they're about to run out of
steam i think our assessment is that the
russians will increasingly find it
difficult to supply manpower material
over the next few weeks they will have
to pause in some way
and that will give the ukrainians
opportunities to strike back
president putin doesn't appear to be
suffering any sort of medical demise
but if the mi6 spy chief is right
the same can't be said for his war
prospects
debra haynes sky news aspen